this week we're talking about bigquery
ml and the speed-read engine and welcome
to this weekend cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news bigquery's have
been adding so many capabilities lately
it can be hard to keep up thankfully
this post captures it all from a
supersize streaming quota to built-in
support for federated cloud sequel
queries find out what's new and bigquery
and how you can try these out for
yourself have you seen what's possible
when you combine the best of bigquery
and cloud a I platform a great place to
start is ml forecasting a business
critical challenge when dealing with
time series data with this code packed
guide you'll see how the framework and
bigquery can be used to help with all
sorts of predictions while you're at it
see how big query can help you create
models for one more difficult task
patent landscaping at Google we're
sharing a methodology that uses Python
and bigquery to allow you to easily
access patent data and generate
automated landscapes read our guide then
grab the code from github and start
mapping your own looking for a quicker
way to keep up with hot cloud topics the
Google cloud blog is the new home for
the speed read by Quentin Hardy a New
York Times editor with decades of
experience observing the tech sector
Quinton believes we have a tendency to
overcomplicate technological change and
he's here to put things into perspective
check out the speed read and stay tuned
to the google cloud blog for more posts
if you want to read about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link have any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you